I have traveled to rock oma a village
and Rhonda in East Africa I am here
because of jean-claude he's 19 hey how
are you I'm fine to me it feels awkward
but I was asked to bring a football and
it does do its magic as an icebreaker
and you also play football right
jean-claude takes me on a tour around
the house yeah he shows me the goats
that he takes care of after school I
know that his family is not like any
other family in the village and
jean-claude is not like the others in
his family he's the only one who never
met his father the only parent he knows
is his mother piata and it wasn't until
a few years ago that she finally told
her son why he would never be able to
meet his father a Chicago fateh in da
Gama no longer TV mu kazem as an allergy
season a gap an indica cool why didn't a
girl quit Jonnie R am dirty nagham
knowingly cool no qualms moves in album
Uzi Arab in gear nani mo I'm giro di DN
top gear econo annually I'm gear
aconitum Rosie trivia Sinatra ET de
originality sure and has your mother
told you about the events when she was
raped and how this happened
he say ciao Tom get a look wanna watch
another Rahul going with it I'm get on
going that Jim Lee Coleman about being
here to say who I get out how a teeny
vyrogen ago bjs a coilover article
didn't we generally be enough that we
engage I learned that be atif let the
village 20 years ago during the genocide
Hutu militia men killed hundreds of
thousands of Tootsie's like the artist
family she tells me she escaped death
but was brutally raped many times by
different men on her journey that's when
she got pregnant with drunk Lord which
one's a charm isn't home why did you
decide to keep the baby in Allenwood
came home Tora Bora hace una Manzana
volume or ten years of not what William
holla at you bruh zenovich copepod amor
es una nagas a [ __ ] multiniche ax 3 g's
and I'm career of Craig ahora Karamu
bonacci Lucy anarchic ie which is an
organic opera and phenomenal in Canada
quit
volvo kilometer in durham lake and
oregano throw it here from the village
of roo coma my drivers taking me on a
trip rwanda has a lush green landscape
and to me it all looks peaceful it's
hard to imagine that only 20 years ago a
brutal genocide took place right here I
am visiting a memorial a former catholic
church in the town of Nia Mata the
memorial contains the remains of more
than 45,000 victims more than 10,000 was
not at right here it feels creepy but
suddenly also very real there are
coffins on display
and hundreds of Skiles in my head they
invoke horrible images of murder
in the former main church building I
meet Freddy moot Angua who survived the
genocide and now study said they'd
broken the door and they start throwing
grenades inside but people issue that
you can see even people were shooted
from boy many side because they came in
into people you can see there's a mom
how to call it the Black Max their
diesel bloods actually some map because
of a grenades they were throwing and
many people actually in them too much
blood and brains and and people just
have their arm chops they can actually
goes up today yes matches on the wars
all clothes you can see here they are
all victims if you count one closest one
victims as there's so many people
actually were inside the year in 1994 in
only 100 days more than half a million
people were killed the perpetrators read
up to 500,000 women as a reside around
20,000 children were born they didn't
have any I love they didn't have any ice
table really psychology to make them
human being so as a consequence of the
rape during genocide the children who
came who was were born from the rape
they have so many challenges in terms of
relationships in terms of how they
should adjust themselves a no mature
children
back in the village I want to find out
how wrong Claude is coping with the
difficult situation with his mother
hello hello oh you oh hey good to see
you again
when be at I leaves us in the banana
Grove I asked to include how he felt
when his mother mistreated him as a
child you know when I gotta be gentle
Queen Jarrah I was like we're kind of
another cool how did meet kind of
Canadians in our eco the money when I
did I wouldn't hurt jack n de- Kahuku
Akira Morikawa Mundy I didn't understand
that sounds very wise but I think when
you are tired you don't understand that
and I'm wondering didn't I mean how did
you react then did you not get mad
sometimes or did you not want to hit
somebody back or something my name is
Erica veto any new jolly joker in DJ
render our grinder bugs innovate 09 Tina
when I began the week you entered when I
remain I think I'll see shakira on go
Nova tazara I know it's not just John
Claude who suffer I wonder how his
mother be artists dealing with her
trauma of being raped she takes me to a
meeting that's for women only Columbia
with them under Korea in their regular
get togethers the women make baskets
that will earn them some extra money and
they also get a chance to talk among
themselves in private all these women
lost relatives in the genocide and many
have experienced sexual violence to
Grenada China too granular yo creo baka
to create a locally locally ponga nature
to Bamako Giza guanajuato Twitter much
Jean Claude's way to let off steam and
forget about his problems is playing
football with his friends I can't help
but wonder if after all that's happened
to his family he can imagine having
children of his own one day and what
kind of father you would be the cool
Quinn de jugar near and I were analyzed
attorney then when the Cougar never know
in this journey and then when the hookah
LOL around attorney hangover yes we go
boom ba qin na ginawa ng wahoo he
dismiss chimneys and this I feel humbled
by Jean Claude's positive outlook his
family has really swim the worst and
humanity and yet they have chosen not to
let hatred govern their lives
with the song the family wishes that I
will come back one day I'd love to
return to see jean-claude as a father